03 developing this morning let's look
back three weeks ago the clark county
school board fired superintendent dr
jesus jarrah they didn't give a reason
they didn't have to but early this
morning trustees changed their mind
so board members reversed that decision
to terminate dr jarrah's contract he
wasn't at the meeting we didn't expect
him to be there but this morning there's
no indication he even wants the job back
hector mejia live near flamingo and
mcleod where public comments went late
into the night all the way into the
morning hector
yeah that board meeting going until
almost two this morning 2 a.m and at
first it seemed like trustees were on
the same page but that did not last long
for the most part on display we saw a
more cohesive school board that's when
you compare last night to previous
meetings but those outbursts were
inevitable during public comments and
between trustees especially when it was
time to bring back discussions over dr
jesus jarrow's contract eventually in a
split decision trustees reversed their
decision from weeks ago now voting to
not fire him as superintendent the board
also voted to reconsider the termination
for convenience meaning the board did
not have to provide a reason
[Music]
the motion that i brought forward on
1028
was not to
get rid of jarrah as superintendent it
was to terminate his contract
now
is that if this was a
paper contract and we terminated it be
gone
um i'm not
an expert in contracts what drives me
the most crazy here is that there was no
plan i voted thinking maybe they have a
plan but there was no plan there i was i
was secretly hoping that there was a
super secret backdoor deal plan
okay so clearly there was and still is
plenty of confusion at the district also
on the agenda the board voted to bring
in an outside expert to investigate
allegations of a hostile work
environment and dr jarliss last day as
superintendent is expected to be
december first the school board attorney
marianne miller said there is a
possibility he will not accept their
decision to now try and keep him here as
superintendent reporting live hector
mejia live local now